man bootleg keV sit in front of me my
favorite thing in the WWE right now
these guys are amazing the new day yes
yeah
Sonic look guys you guys are like I
gotta admit first of all let me be
extremely honest when you guys first
debuted as a new day
I hated it oh my god hey whose kid is
this oh we going on no but you guys you
guys that really treat really like like
made this thing something special like
it's crazy like you I think what you
guys are doing is incredible especially
like I was talking to UM Apollo Cruz and
I felt like Kofi you kind of come out of
your shell a little bit being around
these guys but how do you guys like what
is you guys friends before the the the
formation of new new day or was just
kind of cool I was friendly I had
nothing out with Kofi that much but he's
eating me try to like Claude and get a
job so let me put coke a because you can
try to breeze over this but it was
actually like a big deal so like we had
a developmental basically our minor
league farming strain in Atlanta deep
south and we're all you know practicing
whatever I've been there for like a
couple months or whatever and all of a
sudden the door swings open and in comes
Xavier woods you know eyes wide open
he's got like a resume business casual
and this is like unheard of for us we're
just like who is this stranger walking
in got a resume and he brings a resume
to arrest us so he brings it in he's
like oh yeah I know can I get ot
Hamiltons or something give it to him
you give it to Jodi Hamilton or whatever
very next day deep south close down oh
wow he told me like yeah you can start
coming to shows you know what they
really like yeah literally cut school
that day and drove from South Carolina
to Georgia and date and then it closed
and then it closed down we reopened in
Florida especially W in Tampa and this
is when it was like a warehouse like
yeah built it up and had shows and
everything but it was a warehouse like
canned food soda weird stuff everywhere
no AC no cross-breeze one ringing
and same thing all of a sudden fakery
Woods comes did he have his resume the
same exactly like it works for me I'm
gonna do it he's like oh yeah can I say
you know give us a Steve Curren who is
somebody who's just oh yeah I'm Steve
Byrne and I can't be like no you're not
we're Steve I'm like yeah you don't
really doesn't necessarily know Steve
Corino I knew it was but like this guy
was like thirty right and I'm like here
takes it you know the helping comes of
it or whatever so I was real happy when
he got signed man because like obviously
like I have no I had no idea like what
his actual struggle was but from the
perspective of him being the only person
in all of the you know two years I spent
some developmental to walk in the front
door and hand their resume in really
showed me that like this guy like
definitely wants it you know what I'm
saying so when he actually got signed
and it's pretty impressive and I just
saw Jericho posted of a high school
picture of you as a restaurant you've
come a long way Xavier you've come on
come up oh you're still our we have a
nerd let's go yeah yeah which is why we
love you Tori of getting into the
businesses no it's not good so there's
the word story Coco talks about one of
the listeners he was a kid and going to
the Indies and all these try the
tribulations my story is that I play
college football I was a failed football
player in college and then someone just
came up to me and said hey you want to
try this for living was like yeah sure
I'll give it a shot they put me down the
table for trial and I got signed so they
like they wanted they busted and they
want to do this thing walked in and I
was like yeah I'll give it a shot
train and it worked out so yeah like
usually so that the way we usually do
interviews is co people tell his story
would to tell his stories these
beautiful stores as means like a just
kind of like look let's be clear baby
likes and you are you're physically a
freak you are gigantic reciate boss but
uh but yeah that was a friend like when
you first debuted and you were you know
hanging out with AJ and Dolph I was like
yo this guy is like even like you used
to look I want to keep talking about
your physical yeah yeah oh yeah no we're
snores oh but no um you guys are
honestly on a great run and I feel like
you guys have really revitalized
like the tag-team division which I mean
there's been some Heil like there's some
high points but but nothing like what
you guys are doing right now yeah you
should you are you guys aware of what
you're doing because it's it's crazy
like like this little kids gotta get em
unicorn neighing at home boy yeah so
essentially our whole mentality is that
wrestling change so when we watching as
kids it was a variety show you had like
The Godfather New Age Outlaws Triple A
yeah Roger core like all these different
characters so each 15 minutes was a
completely different kind of fire show
and so we watched that as kids and we
see the rock strong but we see like
these larger-than-life Shawn Michaels
like we want to be that badass guy so I
feel like a lot of guys who started
wrestling from that era created
themselves in that manner so like that's
what we have so it became less a variety
show and so I feel like we tried to say
well fans at watch wrestling like
they're gonna watch wrestling and they
have like let's say they have Owens they
have Neville dan80 they have Joe so like
they have these wrestlers these real
yeah these guys there's no character
where's where's like fun yes we wanted
to kind of be this part of the show to
cook in people that aren't wrestling
fans like let's say so like tons of guys
send us pictures of like their four year
old daughters and they don't know to say
Oh new day like there's oh we let the
unicorn guys but now that dad can watch
wrestling with his daughter and they
didn't have that moment before right
right right now they're taking more
people to the shows and let's be clear
you guys can wrestle oh yeah let's maybe
like to get it in is because we knew I
wanted something different let's go to
Bosnia pause but we wanted to make sure
that our the promos are funny I love the
entertainment stuff is there but you
have to show that you can go in the ring
because we're just a comedy act and the
ring you guys well as a sort self life
so once you've been like once you can
prove that you could have programs that
people are invested in because they're
excited for the promos but they're also
into the matches as well so that's a big
thing too and that's going to give us a
lot more longevity is having both
aspects I will say this last year I
talked to Paul Heyman and I told him and
it was the truth I literally would watch
raw every week to watch his promos
oh man it's amazing and now I feel like
he hasn't been cut as many promos but
now I feel the same way about like I
can't wait
what kind of crazy haha random just
stuff you guys come up with and and like
would like you guys you you guys with
the promos and just playing off each
other it is very impressive that you
guys do that on the I don't want to say
on the fly but you guys do it and don't
mess up like so ginger stuff we do
that's all I'm saying like what is the
like so you guys are on your way to raw
okay guys I got an idea
no like it's organic the inside jokes
that we have in the car while we're out
in the ring is gonna Katt Williams
getting beat up by seventh-grader joke
yet oh we have it we complete video cool
thing is I think a lot of the factions
and teams and ie do what you want in
your free time but a lot of people don't
ride together they don't spend that time
together we've been working on this idea
how long was it before we were even on
TV together about six months where they
let us like we were like hey we started
working on this idea where they just let
us go on live event so we would spend
those Fridays Saturdays Sundays all the
way through TVs like five days a week
still travel together so our chemistry
is is so good because I'll just see
these guys like six days a week
we're I mean we're on the road so much
and we try to not just at work but in
the cars we go to you know we eat
together we train together we do so much
together and we're so on point because
we spend up we invested all that time
right and because the the love is real
it's real like friendship like these
dudes are like legit my brothers and
hopefully 20 30 years from now we'll
still be calling each other and I got
stuck playing you guys will probably be
in the Hall of Fame together and
separately - you never know - cofey so
you guys you obviously are on the road
together a lot yeah I know you n CM punk
travel a ton again good
you guys are real cool we are what's the
difference between traveling with a guy
like CM Punk who seems to be no bit of a
hard-ass and then these two goofy
bastards right I mean I think the punk
kid I know is different than a lot of
the right in the pocket other people
know um for me I was always grateful
that uh
he kind of went out of his way to kind
of take me under his wing like I
remember very specifically on my debut
there was a lot of people like it was
kind of like an era where people were
kind of almost like out for themselves
and I wanted to see like the new guys
fail you know what I'm saying a lot of
like harassment in the locker room right
and I was doing push-ups and like I'll
never forget cuz he you know came up I
saw his speedy ID like his Atomics shoes
on whatever and I look up and it's pugs
okay you're on piece of advice remember
that they came out here to see you I'm
like yeah okay you know so just like put
me at ease and then from that moment on
like he always took me under his wing
and we're riding partners and you know
he's definitely like a brother to me too
so it was more of a I don't know like
I've always looked up to him you know
what I'm saying and I've always been
grateful so I like have the utmost
respect for him you know just kind of
like this big brother-type
relationship that we have right and it
was definitely fun and everything you
know cool like I learned a lot from him
but us you didn't have to deal with like
him probably playing video games all the
time and no ever get it this guy's
playing with me yeah oh yeah boy since
he brings like the video games on the
road is like the owns I might get to
play actually watches are you guys I'm
subscribed to the YouTube channel
good stuff going up down down I'll check
it out on YouTube I'm trying it that
five hundred thousand subscribers that's
all your YouTube check must be kind of
day today
I mean
she did he did he knows I know and then
no we're know it but yeah you know what
I'm saying like it's uh I think in that
point in my career I was a lot more
apprehensive you know because people who
see Punk in public sometimes might you
know think he's like standoffish or
whatever a lot of times like I'd be like
I don't want said like I cared a lot
more about what people thought but I was
you know kind of nervous like step on
toes or just kind of like cut loose and
now at this point in my career like with
these guys legit like they were saying
what we do behind the scenes is exactly
what we do on TV so you see that like
real energy you know you see like us in
you know beating our and I was across so
just like it comes across very natural
yeah obviously is so I think it's
something that helps us a lot too
because a lot of times I feel like guys
can not start to rest on their laurels
but like they'll come out during promos
and kind of do the same sort of stick
but anyway but as you know like with
your friends your inside jokes you've
got like your staples but like they're
constantly changing because we're
constantly talking about new things and
so that's how our promos are because
that's how our guys our banter is so
late unless what we draw from so like it
helped us a lot in that aspect so we
want to think as hard as well in our
short and do and what you said about
walking on eggshells a weird cause I
makes me think back and Punk's been
great to me and I know like everyone
knows about you like she the punko punko
great behind the scenes with me
and actually probably even be around one
for punk so we end up like working a
match on like Raw and SmackDown that
really turned things around for me so at
the time I was doing a little nothing
but I remember on a live event like I
was a serious bodyguard still with the
AJ and Dolph and like someone think I'll
put these pink glasses on me and I like
want to take them off but like punk talk
to me afterwards he's like hey man just
don't be afraid to let loose a little
bit like when you first got on the mic
like you had that like I thought you
could tell you where a character off for
often the junk yeah yeah I tried to but
I guy was so concerned with being taken
seriously and and like that was a big
thing and like oh I don't want to ruffle
feathers but it's so weird to look back
now come be like go compare that like oh
I can't step on eggshells and now some
of the stuff we're doing like it is like
borderline vulgar and it makes me like
so happy
but I heard you guys are you guys are
investing the Freebirds yeah yeah sure
which is that's pretty crazy because
obviously it's a three-person tag-team
yeah sure how do you guys feel about
about it's cool because obviously like
we draw from that with the freebird rule
you guys the Nam
so they kind of set the precedent for us
to be able to even do this so it's cool
to be able to pay homage and you know
say thank you I'm like a grander stage
and inducting all things so it's a cool
thing and it's definitely an honor to be
able to do that you guys got a cool
relationship with a well Michael Hayes I
mean he's our boss you know keep me
posted
live in seas around all the time so we
we get a mark a little bit pause a thing
like I don't like people don't see this
so so Michael thinks he's like every
time I see my class is gone too far but
people think I want to gyrate all the
time like I do it on TV I do it like
it's funny to me but people see me and I
just come up and like when I have a
dance battle or a gyration battle and
Michael will do that at TV so every time
I seen you come around the corner he
like hey but it's like jewelinx angelo
stage look at each other not get in the
swing draw and no and they just start
don't get caught in between you and let
them you know this right this is this
has to get on video some I don't know I
don't know you know you might say me my
c1 oh everybody's lookin Congrats on the
success you guys are I know you guys
gonna shut it down to WrestleMania the
booty oh is there gonna be some you by
ever well hopefully hopefully we'll sing
a lot of tomato no actual cereal right
now it's a collector's edition box which
is awesome so many new day and booty
references it's a very witty box yeah
you know so it's really cool comes
t-shirt in it so who do you know who the
thought real quick what are you doing I
know enemy you and I have a lot of
similar tastes hey Bob what you
listening oh right now I love club of
zombies so most menus
my lazy Odyssey and his dope actually uh
so I talked to juice I was in the
zombies yeah almost like every week and
it was really cool to be in the liner
notes for the album says pretty cool so
that's kind of what I'm listening now a
lot like a lot of Pisco stuff yeah so
that way for the travel enjoyed that SP
uh I don't know like like rat beef is
weird to me like nowadays cuz like it
was cool like when I was a kid but it's
come on like go up and I'm like Troy
have some stuff dad you should have said
especially of course yeah you know but
you know you know those those guys lost
lost someone was important to him so
right like you know referencing people
who passed isn't isn't cool so you know
uh but it's kind of nonsensical to move
word Apple look new day it was nice to
meet y'all you to message I'm actually
mad cuz I was waiting for you to say
something like you know insulting or be
bad so I can make a booty like keV you
didn't give me the opening Mary I'm